when the doctors diagnosed me they told
me that I wouldn't be able to clothe
myself
or feed myself that I would need
assistance for pretty much everything I
did my body is more than just fact it's
actually an instrument to do great
things with and I've been a professional
dancer for six years I'm Doron Herman
and I have come ablaze of cerebral palsy
cerebral palsy is a neuromuscular
disorder that a sex
message is going to see muscles in your
body so the result is involuntary motion
and spasticity hemiplegia refers to me
because it affects only the left side of
my body
I left he dance is a company that
integrates people with disabilities I've
always been advocate for those to pursue
the antithesis of the thing that is
their limitations why dance primarily
because of the physical diagnosis I was
given my body is the instrument and if
I'm a disabled person in my body's
instrument it's pretty pretty audacious
as I've been told my arabesque is crazy
but it's for my left side and it comes
from my left leg shooting up to the air
and my balance is based on my right side
being the main impetus for all for my
control so that these things that were
perceived as negative are now folded
into the choreography when I am in the
moment and I'm dancing I feel just calm
that I've got this
everything is working together and then
some dance has relieved me of
stereotypes that is play something with
disabilities
[Music]
you